we've reported how university of north
carolina trustees agreed to offer tenure
to journalist nicole hannah jones
after weeks of controversy she is here
with us now for her first interview
since the offer was approved
it was approved last week wednesday july
1st nicole hannah jones we welcome you
to cbs this morning
thank you so much what have you decided
to do we just heard the vote was nine to
four offering
offering you the tenure what have you
decided well i've decided to
decline the offer of tenure i will not
be teaching on the faculty of the
university of north carolina at chapel
hill
it's a very difficult decision not a
decision i wanted to make
and instead i'm going to be the
inaugural night chair
in race and journalism at howard
university so many things to unpack
there first let's start with you
declining the offer the vote was nine to
four
clearly in your favor there are some
people that could say
you said you wouldn't take the job
without being offered tenure they
offered you the tenure and you're still
saying
thanks but no absolutely because well
because
look what it took to get tenure so this
was a position
that since the 1980s came with tenure
the night chairs are designed for
professional journalists
who have been working in the field to
come into academia and
every other chair before me who also
happened to be white
received that position with tenure i it
has never been denied no one had never
been denied tenure before
exactly and i went through the tenure
process and i received
the unanimous approval of the faculty
to be granted tenure and so to be denied
it
and to only have that vote occur on the
last possible day
at the last possible moment after threat
of legal action
after weeks of protests after it became
a national scandal
it's just not something that i want
anymore because there were two chances
it seems to me they could have voted for
tenure in november
then you heard that the 10-year offer
was being pulled
did anybody explain why it was being
pulled no gail to this day
neither the chancellor or the provost or
anyone on the board of trustees has ever
told me
why my tenure was not taken up in
november why it was not taken up in
january
and even the public statements about
needing more information
about my credentials they voted without
ever
asking me or receiving any additional
information than what they had
in november now at one point i believe
there was an offer that you could work
there you could
teach for five years and then they would
reconsider tenure and it seems at one
point you had accepted that offer right
i did you do that and what what changed
your mind well i accepted it
after going through months and months of
the tenure process
this is my alma mater i love the
university the university
has given me a lot and i wanted to give
back it was embarrassing to be the first
person
to be denied tenure it was embarrassing
and i didn't
want this to become a public scandal i
didn't want to drag my university
you know through the the pages of
newspapers because i was the first and
the only
black person in that position to be
denied tenure so i was willing to accept
it yeah you never
thought it would be during that time
never if this did not become public
because of anything that i did
as you know this is the first time i'm
speaking about this at all
why do you suppose they didn't right
away offer you tenure
what do you think the reason is i mean
what
has been reported is that there was a
great deal of political
interference by conservatives who don't
like the work that i've done
particularly the 1619
project and also by the powerful donor
who gave the largest donation
in the 70 year history of the journalism
school so it's pretty clear
that my tenure was not taken up because
of political opposition
because of discriminatory views against
my viewpoint
and i believe my race and my gender yeah
let's talk should politics be part of
this process
no things have become very very
political yeah
it's actually against uh state law for
political interference to be part of the
tenure process so no it clearly
shouldn't
uh every every person who comes up from
tenure should
be judged by the quality of their work
by how they went through the the tenure
process you know
again it has to be made clear i went
through the official tenure process
and my peers in academia said that i was
deserving of tenure
these board members are political
appointees who decided that i wasn't and
can we say you have a 20-year career
with impeccable credentials
let's talk about the 16-19 project
because the new york times did issue a
clarification not a correction
they said they've stood by you there was
a clarification what was the
clarification and how what is your
response
to the criticism sure so the
clarification was that we added two
words
to a statement on the role of slavery in
the american revolution
the original text right the original
text said that
uh one of the primary reasons that
colonists decided to break off from the
british empire
was to preserve slavery we added that
one of the primary reasons that some of
the colonists decided to break off
it was a clarification and i think you
know in academia and in journalism
we should clarify if necessary that's
never been seen
somehow as making a project illegitimate
because you try to strengthen and
clarify your argument you know we've you
you've risked
you've released a eight-page statement i
encourage people to read the statement
it's eight pages where you really take
us through exactly what happened
i want people to understand you had
offers from many universities
after this controversy started to arise
with north carolina
many people approached you and said
please come here um
including howard why did you decide that
it would be howard and i raise that
question because some would say
look howard already understands this
would you be more effective working for
say a predominantly white university
that may need to understand
the work that you do yeah you know i
have been very very thoughtful about
my decision to go to an historically
black college
and what i decided is since the second
grade when i started being bussed into
white schools
i've spent my entire life proving that i
belonged
in elite white spaces that were not
built for black people
and i just decided you know i got a lot
of clarity through
what happened with the university of
north carolina i decided i didn't want
to do that anymore
that black professionals should feel
free and actually perhaps an obligation
to go to our own institutions and bring
our talents and resources
to our own institutions and help to
build them up as well this is not my
fight
i fought the battle that i wanted to
fight which is i deserve to be treated
equally and have a vote on my tenure i
won that battle
but it's not my job to heal the
university of north carolina that's the
job of the people in power who created
this situation in the first place
are there any other reasons and they
never gave you reasons but are there any
other reasons that you could think of
other than the 1619 project
that they would delay your tenure or
that this would become
a controversy absolutely not if anyone
looks at my track record as a journalist
i work at the new york times look at the
awards i've won look at the work that
i've done
i wish that we could make public you
know the letters of recommendation from
others in the field um it is clear that
i was credentialed enough to teach 18
year olds
how to do journalism at the university
of north carolina
so i don't think anyone can say that
there was any other reason
other than political appointees did not
like the nature of my work and that is
illegal discrimination
had you told north carolina your
decision before
joining us today we like an inclusive
always but had you
do inform them that this was a decision
you were going to make
i told dean susan king who has been a
tremendous advocate for me
who has been one of the few leaders who
has shown i think a great deal of
integrity during this process
i told members of the carolina black
caucus
and i told the group of student
protesters i went down to north carolina
this past weekend so that i could tell
them in person how grateful i was for
their support
how appalled i was at the way that the
students were treated at the board of
trustees meeting
um and that i wasn't coming because i
didn't want them to feel betrayed
but as for uh the chancellor and the
provost
i didn't because i haven't heard from
them since this happened so i didn't
feel anything you haven't heard from
them absolutely not
what is a personal toll it's taken on
you you started when you read your your
statement you said listen
you've been a tar heels fan since you
were a little girl watching the games go
heels i know you're supposed to say that
when you talk about
north carolina but you've been a fan for
a very long time what has this meant
to you personally how has this affected
you personally
it's been extremely difficult
um people see me as some type of
a symbol of things either they they love
or they hate
but i'm a human being i didn't ask for
this
i um you know i really just wanted to
give back to the place that has given me
so much this same year i was inducted
into the north carolina media hall of
fame
by the university of north carolina um
the organization i founded the iw wealth
society for investigative reporting
is housed at the university of north
carolina i was so excited
to have the opportunity to engage with
students the way that my professors
engaged with me
and this has been one of the most
difficult periods of my life which is
why i've been
really silent about it and how do you
feel about going to howard i know at
howard i would imagine they are doing
the hula that they have nicole hannah
jones
on their staff yeah you know your good
friend oprah told me
at one point on another project that she
felt i was in a supreme moment of
destiny
and that is how i've been thinking about
howard university
one of my few regrets in life is that i
didn't go to howard as an undergraduate
and i have long wanted to be a part of
the howard family
and it's just so clear that this is the
right thing for me to do at this moment
howard has an amazing journalism program
as you know
i'm bringing with me at this point 15
million dollars in in resources to
help build up investigative reporting in
journalism at howard and other
historically black college
colleges i'm trying to raise a total of
25 million so to be able to bring that
type of resources
um to a university that always punches
above its weight
uh i'm so excited something great came
out of this
i think we will say congratulations to
you nicole hannah jones and we'll
we'll get a statement from university of
north carolina
thank you so much for telling us this
morning thank you